[Music]
this is lbc news
with phillip chris across lbc news time
23 minutes past one good afternoon we
start with our dominating story that of
the government not denying reports that
a rise in national insurance is under
consideration to pay for social care
plans ministers are believed to be
preparing to announce an increase of at
least one percent maybe as high as two
percent for around 25 million workers
next week joining me live on lbc news is
a gary stevenson who's an inequality
economist
gary thank you for your time this
afternoon your reaction to uh this story
to be honest uh it's pretty shocking
really let's look at the situation we're
in now so i think to explain to the
listeners we'll talk a little bit about
the numbers okay the government
apparently needs an extra 10 billion
pounds a year to pay for social care all
right well in the last one year what's
happened to the economy okay well
ordinary people many have lost their
jobs lost their incomes but the super
rich made a fortune right the richest
person in the country leonard blavatnik
has made over seven billion pounds in
the last year so he can nearly pay for
this himself the mitel family have made
eight billion and the reuben family made
five billion so just three families in
the last one year the money they've made
during kobe could pay for this social
care need twice over and by cristiano
ronaldo about 35 times on top of that
and yet in spite of that the government
whose chancellor which is the next
family are themselves billionaires have
chosen instead of taxing the
billionaires they're going to tax
ordinary working people and it's going
to be if it's one percent an extra 200
pound tax on an ordinary person if it's
two percent an extra four hundred pounds
so while leonardo dicaprio that makes it
make seven billion pounds ordinary
workers are going to pay extra 400 a
year well why do you think the
government is is putting this on these
uh ordinary workers some arguing that uh
it could be boris johnson the prime
minister's defining moment because
despite saying in the uh 2019
conservative party election manifesto
that this wasn't going to happen this
could be him uh taking metal by the
horns and and really running with it
phil i wish on you i wish i knew i mean
you know if i was a fly on the wall in
the conservative party office i'd be
able to tell you why i think it might
have something to do with the fact that
the chancellor
himself comes from a billionaire family
and that might lead him to have a
reluctance to tax billionaires but i
mean let's look at the numbers here
right national insurance that is a tax
which affects only working people it
does not apply to billionaires who get
their income from wealth so if you've
got an income of 30 000 pounds you'll
pay an extra 200 400 pound a year but if
you're a billionaire family like
richardson's family you'll get an income
of about 30 million pounds from that
wealth and you'll pay zero so the
numbers here are ordinary working family
30 grand a year extra tax 400 pounds
billionaire family like richard synax
income 30 million pounds a year extra
tax zero you know these guys talk about
leveling up
i'm not quite sure what kind of level up
this is other than making everybody poor
except the billionaires perhaps finally
gary is this a a a an idea for more
people moving over
to being self-employed where there's a
different national insurance tax rate to
those who are going to be affected by
this if it is pushed through uh who are
employed and uh on payroll
i mean look ordinary working people who
are increasingly being squeezed by tax
while the rich pay nothing they're
understandably going to look for ways
around this to pay less taxes and you
can totally understand that while the
super rich aren't paying their fair
share but realistically i think if
ordinary people want to oppose paying
more tax they're really going to have to
come together and pressure this
government to change their focus away
from taxing ordinary hard-working
families and towards taxing super-rich
families like the one our chancellor
belongs to okay gary stevenson a
inequality economist thank you for your
time this afternoon housing could be so
much more affordable wages could be so
much higher and we could have so many
more options in how we live our lives
some of them put a lot of money into
paying economists and think tanks to
tell you that inequality is important
for the economy
that is not true
[Music]